c'est la première ligne de front pour
voir du personnel de la santé les
pharmacies un service essentiel pour le
public mais à l'ère du coville 19
ce n'est pas le moment de se chercher un
ami chez jean coutu ici on a installé
des plexiglas de festi glace en fait
c'est conçu dans le but de protéger les
gens contre les gouttes la saline après
c'est ce qui est important que pas de
danger ni pour vous ni pour le personnel
dans la pharmacie
on nettoie tous les chariots les
surfaces on veut surtout que les clients
changent leurs habitudes des gens même
si russie appelait d'avant nous
délivrerons ça explose aussi pour éviter
que les gens restent au contrôle chez
focus le moins longtemps dans la
pharmacie
jacques l'air d'en devenir pour m'éviter
de rester longtemps ici la pharmacie est
ferme et véronique magnan a pris les
grands moyens
désormais les clients doivent appeler
ont mis sur un service de livraison est
une décision de pharmacienne et pas
nécessairement de commerçante
c'est un peu la folie à la pharmacie on
voyait que les gens respectent pas les
consignes d'isolement ont des vingt peut
le jouer à la police les chicanes et de
laver les mains à l'entrée de respecter
les distances de 2 mètres entre chaque
client et chaque employé alors là on
appuie cette décision là pour vraiment
se concentrer sur les services
professionnels aux patients
derrière le comptoir le nombre de
commandes a explosé chaque client prend
ses réserves de médicaments pour 30
jours maximum
là j'ai beaucoup de paniers préparer les
gens là ils veulent un peu les obtenir
en avance le cette semaine parce
qu'ensuite ils veulent être tranquilles
le téléphone ne dérougit pas cette
semaine le système téléphonique chez
jean coutu a flanché
il était à 300 % de sa capacité un
niveau de surcharge jamais vu auparavant
beaucoup de stress beaucoup de pression
beaucoup d'appels puis des gens qui
viennent
et c'est pas de temps qu'on les aime
nous perçons arrangé mais on dit aux
gens restez chez vous pouvez prendre une
marche à l'ordre des pharmaciens du
québec ont fait appel aux retraités pour
qu'ils viennent prêter main forte
on a besoin que certains retraités
reviennent parce qu'on a des pharmaciens
est pharmacienne qui sont en isolation
peut avoir et il a ce message pour le
public
on demande aux gens d'être gentil d'être
courtois bête un peu patient on est
débordé mais oui on voyait arriver on
l'espère une accalmie de commandes de
médicaments
une accalmie avant la tempête ici à 0,2
york 10 radio canada mon frère